a british man who was part of a group of
islamic state fighters dubbed the
beatles has just been sentenced our
correspondent david blevins is at the
court in alexandria in virginia david
bring us up to speed
alexander cote left his home in london
went to syria where he joined isis was
eventually detained ended up in a u.s
courtroom where in the last few minutes
minutes he has been sentenced to life
without parole he will never be a free
man again his co-accused al-shafi
al-shaikh had denied involvement in a
major hostage-taking operation but was
found guilty by a jury here and while he
will not be sentenced himself until
later this year the judge did insist
that he be in court today to hear victim
impacts impact statements from the
families of those who were so cruelly
taken many people will remember
the murder of the american journalist
jim foley freelance journalist had gone
to syria to document the impact of the
war on the lives of civilians there his
killing which was captured on video
released to the world really introduced
all of us to the brutality of an
organization we now know as isis there
were many other victims two american
journalists two u.s aid workers and two
british aid workers david haynes and
alan henning now
the two men who were standing
before the judge today basically had
repeatedly attempted to excuse their
crimes they did that in a series of
television interviews including one for
sky news but their victims families
today made it very clear to them that
what damage they had done in a series
one by one of harrowing victim impact
statements they paid a tribute to their
relatives they talked about the impact
of losing them on their own mental and
physical health and the mother of one
hostage insisted that the two men look
her in the eye as she talked about the
pain they had caused her but i think
perhaps the most memorable moment in the
courtroom today was when david hen's
brother mike who has traveled here from
the uk to look the two men in the eye
he delivered his victim impact statement
and ended it with the words i forgive
you so
al-shafi al-shaikh will be sentenced
later in the year the third man in this
terror cell muhammad emwazi was killed
in a terror strike they had covered
their faces to try and avoid a
prosecution but ultimately it was their
english accents that revealed their
identity that's why hostages came to
know them as the beetles and why one of
them ended up pleading guilty another
one has been found guilty and just to
recap on the breaking news alexander
cote has now been sentenced to life
without parole the judge described it as
a heinous crime and said he would
consider mr cote's request to serve half
of his sentence here in the united
states and the other half in a british
prison
okay david uh many thanks to breaking
news there terrorist alexander coaty
jailed for life in the us